la vraie question à se poser c'est pas
est ce que je dois acheter un view 2 go
ou un vieux de plus la vraie question à
se poser c'est est ce que je suis j'ai
quelques jours je vous parlais du view 2
go de rico j'ai fait un test de
l'appareil complet au monde a fait le
tour est venu le jour de parler du view
de plus de haricots qui est le grand
frère du vieux 2 go ni plus ni moins il
a des specs un peu plus performante
quelques points en plus par rapport au
vieux 2 go donc ce qu'on va faire
aujourd'hui c'est qu'on va regarder un
petit peu quelle est la vraie différence
entre ces deux produits et au final sur
lequel elle et ça c'est le jeu de go et
là c'est le vieux de plus de produits
qui se ressemblent énormément mais qui
pourtant ont chacun une vraie différence
dans les deux cas vous avez un écran de
5,93 pouces format 19 2e c'est une dalle
ips bsc du lcd
dans les deux cas vous avez un sla
dragon pour liu de go c'est un scindera
gones 430 pont vieux de plus c'est 1 450
d'un côté vous avez 3 giga de ram et de
l'autre côté vous avez 4 gigas de ram et
dans les deux cas vous avez une batterie
de 4000 milliampères heures
ensuite au lieu de go vous avez 32 gigas
de stockage contre 64 giga pour le vieux
de plus que dans les deux cas vous
pouvez monter jusqu'à 256 giga sol view
2 go vous avez une simple caméra de 2
mégapixels tandis que son vieux de plus
vous avez une double caméra 5 + 12
mégapixels à noter que sur le bio de
plus vous avez en plus un capteur
d'empreintes digitales ce qu'ils ne
gâchent pas la fête sur le vieux de go
vous avez une caméra frontale de 5
mégapixels tandis que sur le vieux de
plus vous avez une caméra de 8
mégapixels alors tout ça c'est bien beau
mais au final le cac l'acheter parce
qu'avec toutes ces petites différences
vous avez quand même un vieux 2 go qui
coûte 159,99 euros tandis que le vieux
depuis
scout 249,99 euros soit 90 euros d'écart
on a donc deux produits qu'ils se
ressemblent énormément mais qu'il faut
bien départager faut absolument qu'on
retrouve un brio les départager on peut
déjà le faire au niveau de la boîte
alors c'est sûr ça n'a pas changé grand
chose c'est que la boîte celle du lieu
de gros et plus petite celle du joug de
plus est plus grande
est ce que c'est un choix stratégique
qui est fait par ricco pour vraiment les
différencier sordi peut-être compliqué
d'avoir les mêmes types de boîtes la
botte du vieux de plus se rapproche
davantage de celle du view 2 promet
malgré tout c'est pas là dessus que la
différence va jouer d'adapter plus se
faire d'un point de vue esthétique sur
le vieux de plus vous voyez si votre
double capteur les deux modules dépasse
très légèrement
la vraie différence que vous allez avoir
comme là vous avez un double capteur
photo
c'est ici le petit module flash qui est
positionné juste là autre différence et
pas des moindres cette fois ci sur le
vieux de plus vous avez le capteur
d'empreintes digitales là là vous ne
rêvez pas lui pour le déverrouiller vous
allez facebook que vous avez également
sur le vieux de plus
et sinon vous repartez avec votre bon
vieux code votre bon vieux schémas
pourquoi pas dans les deux cas vous avez
une prise jack sur le dessus du micro
usb pour la recharge et d'un côté comme
de l'autre c'est exactement la même
chose au niveau de la face avant il n'y
a pas non plus de différences encoches
de chaque côté je suis très honnête avec
vous la différence a pas se faire non
plus en termes de performance vous avez
d'un côté instinct dragonne 430 de lot
reste un dragon 453 giga de ram 4 gigas
de ram cadencé jusqu'à 1,4 gigahertz
cadencé jusqu'à 1,5 gigahertz vous êtes
dans la série 410 la dragonne de
qualcomm
ça n'a globalement pas changé grand
chose alors qu'est ce qui justifie une
différence de 90 euros d'écart entre ces
deux machines
est-ce que c'est uniquement le capteur
d'empreintes digitales situé à l'arrière
un snapdragon 450 au lieu de 430 3 giga
de ram au lieu de 4 gigas de ram ou
alors est-ce que la différence devenir
aussi du double module photo l'arrière
alors la vraie différence va se faire au
niveau des photos et surtout du mode
portrait l'âge sur le view 2 go lorsque
je faire une photo en mode portrait j'ai
mon visage ma main côté qui sont
parfaitement bien des tours et ça
fonctionne extrêmement bien la même
chose sur le vieux de plus mais là où la
vraie différence se fait c'est lorsque
vous passez à demain là on va
les limites de view 2 go qui plus du
tout capable de différencier votre
deuxième main de votre première main ma
première main et complètement net tandis
que la deuxième est complètement fou
elles se font avec le reste et là ça
marche plus du tout et pas seulement
sauver le photo je peux en faire une
deuxième
c'est exactement la même chose elle est
complètement flou pourtant les deux
mains sont exactement dans le même plan
tandis que là dessus le vieux de plus
s'en sort extrêmement bien du fait de sa
deuxième caméra de 5 mégapixels vous
avez les deux mains qui sont
complètement d'être complètement
détourné alors si effectivement je peux
venir chipoter ici j'ai le haut du doigt
qui est assez mal délimitée mais sinon
ça fonctionne relativement bien et ça
s'est vraiment bien alors pas que sur
une photo mais sur plein de photos le
détourage est parfait au niveau dés
demain et c'est vraiment la différence
entre ces deux appareils
la vraie différence se fait par rapport
à la photo oui mais pas vraiment elle se
fait surtout par rapport au mode
portrait parce que la première caméra
que vous avez la caméra 2 mégapixels est
identique sur les deux appareils
la vraie différence c'est cette fameuse
deuxième caméra de 5 mégapixels et là
pour le coup une vraie différence parce
que 3 giga août et 4 gigaoctets de
l'autre côté pour moi ça fonctionne
exactement de la même manière on a
exactement le même rendu la même
fluidité nombreux termes de performances
en termes de fluidité d'ouverture
d'applications de navigation
il n'y a pas de différence pour moi
entre le vieux 2 go et le vieux de plus
vous sentirez la différence entre 3 giga
et 4 giga lan 33 sa dragonne 430 et 450
vraiment en plus on danse a franchement
bon voilà pour moi là dessus la
différence elle se fera pas tant plus
par rapport à l'usagé qu'on en a non la
vraie différence ça se fait par rapport
en mode portrait donc la vraie question
à se poser c'est pas est ce que je dois
acheter un view 2 go ou un vieux de plus
la vraie question à se poser c'est
est-ce que je suis prêt avec 90 euros
pour avoir un vrai beau note portrait
pour la caméra arrière de mon smartphone
est ce que je suis prêt à mettre 90
euros de plus pour avoir un capteur
d'empreintes digitales à l'arrière non
smartphones ça pour moi ce sont les
vraies questions à se poser par rapport
à ces appareils lequel choisir entre le
vieux de go le vieux de plus je ne peux
absolument pas y répondre
parce que c'est pas moi qui suis dans
vos finances donc du coup je botte en
touche
en tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est que les
deux se valent en termes d'usagé en
termes de performances en termes
d'utilisation standard la différence
vous
avait sur le mode portrait pour le reste
vous avez une batterie de 4 millions
perreur ça fonctionne c'est exactement
le même écran de 5,93 pousse donc de ce
point de vue là vous êtes aussi
tranquille dites moi vous en commentaire
qu'est ce que vous en pensez
est-ce que vous êtes prêts à mettre 90
euros de plus pour cette fameuse double
caméra est ce que ces 249 euros virgule
99 vous font pas peur
ou alors est ce que vous vous dites à
performance équivalente je vais aller
sur un produit à 159 euros 99 sa frappe
parfaitement bien la faire aimer 90
euros je me le mettre dans un restaurant
dans une coque dans ce que je vois pas
ça c'est à vous de voir ça ne me regarde
absolument pas marquer moi tout ça en
commentaire vous invite bien évidemment
à rester connectés à vous abonner ya
plein de choses qui arrivent
j'ai reçu les meilleurs vins et mets
vins pro qui sont planqués quelque part
par ici j'ai aussi reçu des écouteurs
sans fil de moy pas mal de choses pas
mal de choses à tester
il ya aussi un ordinateur de asus qui
arrive vous allez voir pas mal de trucs
hyper cool donc vous invite à faire une
seule chose c'est à vous abonner
merci à vous marquez matou sans
commentaire dites moi ce que vous pensez
de cette problématique de ces fameux 90
euros prix et on a parlé ensemble
à bientôt
[Musique]